[Music]
don't forget to enter our Amazon
giftcard giveaway all you have to do is
be a subscriber like and comment
hey guys episode 5 just ended and wow
I'm lost for words that's one way to
ruin so many character arcs I guess then
in becoming this mate we know the Saturn
just doesn't make any sense yeah she did
kill bunch master sellards previously
but she never hurt innocent people
the same people shame to protect at the
end they made search to look like the
good one and Danny like the evil one I
just don't like this episode not one bit
I did predict that Danny and the isalud
would go nuts and they even said that
Danny burning the red cape would be
justified and it would not make her the
meat Queen just like he did not make a
cake and the Conqueror the Mad King my
heels dragons to burn down the castles
but they made her burn the entire city
Street by street building by building
she spent the entire episode burning
down entire King's Landing with old eNOS
the people the only thing or two I liked
about this episode was Tyrians emotional
conversation with Jamie how he's the
only one who ever treated him with
respect and the way John tried to
prevent unnecessary killing enemies
let's make a quick breakdown on the
season 8 finale trailer it opens up with
Davos and John walking through the
streets of King's Landing or seeing all
the damage Denny did better joven right
of the bad John is going to kill Danny
after this this Danny's betrayal for
love and deaths have this shovel end the
show unfortunately made Danny the mate
Queen and they did it in one single
episode Varys did warn John he thinks
Danny's going mad and John's saw himself
in the battle King's Landing Tyrion will
probably say the same thing to join in
the next episode and beside that he will
also probably tell him to stop her I
believe Tyrion will tell John about
conversation he had with Dany a gemstone
at the beginning of episode 5 the one
about Sansa and how dana sees her as a
traitor and one plotting to overthrow
her Tyrion will tell John about this
conversation and he will tell him how
Danny sees sense as a threat he just
witnessed her daily deals with those
threats the same way her father the Mad
King did by burning them alive along
with all the innocent to be fair John
already saw for himself that Dany must
be stopped now that she's killed a
couple hundreds of thousand small folk
John tried to stop his armies from
killing enemy armies
John killed his own man who tried to
force himself on a girl during the
Battle of King's Landing how do you
think he'll react affected Danny just
burned in tyre King's Landing and
allowed her armies to brutally slain
women and children John already knows
that he's got to stop Danny and Tyrion
telling him how Danny sees her family
especially since as traitors are
plotting behind her back John will be
forced to kill Danny and even though he
loves her and even though she's probably
pregnant
speaking of Tyrion he's also obviously
upset with Danny I believe he will try
his hand of the kingpin after this and I
also believe Tyrion will die ending
House Lannister then he warned him early
on in Episode five that if he fails
again or does anything against her will
that it will be his last
Tyrion release Jaime from prison and not
only did he release him but everyone
knows it was him Tyrion made good job
identifying himself with the unsullied
guards saying that he is the hand of the
Queen and he commands him to have a word
with the prisoner whereupon his set him
free Tyrion is destroyed not only by a
fact that his siblings Jaime and Cersei
are dead but also by the fact that this
entire time he's supported Dany and
therefore he thinks he is partly
responsible for everything that happened
Tyrion is so destroyed that he doesn't
even bother running but will straight
towards Dany even though he knows he
will be executed or is also upset with
the dragon queen she saw all those
innocent people burn alive and she
herself almost got burned alive at some
point of the episode however I do not
think Danny's green eyes are the green
Ansari will shut forever
Jon will definitely be the one to kill
Danny that's the better seat ending will
get although I don't know what's weird
about is all her favorite characters
that Tyrion Jaime Danny except for John
who will have to kill Danny and then
we'll probably go either on the wall
taking black for killing Danny or going
to the real north
joining ghost and free Faulk a Stroman
said he should one way or another it's
now pretty safe to say that show has
made they need the meth Queen and
general had to stop her by killing her
and as always I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see you in the next one peace